[Musique]
depuis que je suis gamin il ya quelque
chose qui me trotte dans la tête
un petit peu comme une obsession c'est
essayer de changer le monde
je crois que j'ai jamais vraiment digéré
qu'on m'explique que je fais partie de
ce qu'on appelle la génération sacrifiée
vous savez les générations de la fin du
monde celle à qui on répète tout le
temps il faut faire quelque chose il
faut que tu fasses quelque chose sinon
c'est bientôt la fin sinon le monde va
s'effondrer leurs vers l'âge de 9 10 ans
je regardais un dessin animé qui
s'appelle minus et cortex
je sais pas si vous connaissez ces
histoires de cette petite souris cette
petite souris tous les jours elle
échafaude un plan machiavélique pour
conquérir le monde et entre elle et moi
je dois dire que ça a été assez vite le
coup de foudre
parce que cette petite souris elle vient
répondre à la problématique de gamins et
aussi parce qu'elle est très mignonne en
gros si on veut changer le monde
on peut commencer par essayer de le
conquérir comme ça après le monde
il m'appartient je peux en faire ce que
je veux forcément c'est mieux alors
j'attrape quelques livres d'histoire et
je cherche la méthode et la stratégie
d'un certain nombre de personnages qui
sont pas trop mal débrouillé niveau
conquête du monde comme gengis khan
at-il à alexandre le grand
sauf qu'à l'époque faut vous dire que je
veux faire mettre 40 je suis gros suffit
solitaire mais tenace mais c'était pas
là mon plus gros souci
le vrai souci c'est qu'en y regardant de
plus près on s'aperçoit qu'évidemment
vouloir conquérir le monde et le changer
tout seul ça se termine toujours mal en
général on finit seul assez souvent fini
morts la plupart du temps on n'y arrive
pas et puis surtout dans la bande son de
ma vie à ce moment là il y avait une
espèce d'effroyables fausse note
imaginez par exemple la charge des
walkyries de wagner mais sur un cheval à
bascule
et puis c'est vrai que 11 ans un pas de
côté
on s'aperçoit que cortex dans les
épisodes n'y arrive jamais à conquérir
le monde et c'est bien logique parce que
sinon il n'y aurait pas d' épisodes
suivants donc la catastrophe ma
stratégie fonctionne pas je mobilise mon
état major intérieur il faut trouver
absolument autre chose et en
réfléchissant bien je me dis pourquoi
pas essayer de convaincre le monde de se
changer lui-même donc
premier constat si on veut convaincre le
monde entier c'est des milliards de
personnes il vaut mieux être nombreux et
un matin comme ça sans prévenir je me
réveille démocrate je me rapproche d'un
parti politique
et effectivement je suis servi je trouve
plein de gens qui veulent changer le
monde et qui sont prêts à apporter cette
parole là il y avait toujours une fausse
note dans la bande son et c'est vrai que
on y regarde de plus près ces personnes
voulaient changer le monde mais tout
seul
selon leur point de vue avec une vision
très arrêtée de caisse qu'il fallait
changer qu'est-ce qu'il fallait garder
et là aussi avec un pas de côté
on s'aperçoit assez vite que vouloir
être le seul en étant plusieurs bassins
tourne assez vite en ça fonctionne pas
qu'à cela ne tienne je tourne la page de
la politique et je cherche une nouvelle
méthode
je me dis pourquoi pas explorez la
méthode du ver dans la pomme
vous savez la méthode du ver dans la
pomme ça consiste à essayer de faire
naître un changement de l'intérieur
quand on n'arrive pas à la publicité
extérieure pour faire ça il ya
différentes méthodes possibles par
exemple rejoindre l'église et devenir
curé sait plus vraiment à la mode et
s'est pas complètement mon truc ou autre
chose c'est essayer de faire du
journalisme et vous ne direz c'est pas
très éloigné alors va pour le
journalisme là la bande son de ma vie
elle est partie en free jazz
je me retrouve d'abord chez tf1 ensuite
au magazine le point
puis pendant un certain nombre d'années
au figaro alors pour quelqu'un qui veut
changer le monde je vous cache pas que
mon che guevara intérieure s'est étouffé
avec son béret
et puis surtout dans ma vie la fausse
note dans la bande son elle a pris la
dimension d'une vocaliste de death metal
dans un refrain de mireille mathieu au
bout de quelques années à ce régime là
j'avais les oreilles en sont il a fallu
que je me repose il a fallu que je
prenne des vacances avec un grand v du
genre de celle où on peut tout remettre
à plat
revoir ses plans parce que clairement ça
ne fonctionnait pas et par chance à ce
moment là un groupe d'amis que je
connais à peine à l'époque me dit viens
te reposer avec nous de tes année
épuisante on a un plan génial on va
partir dans le désert dans le nord de
l'espagne dans un endroit où il fait 45
degrés il n'y a pas de route pas d'eau
pas d'électricité
y'a rien à faire à part les activités
qu'on amène et je vous cache pas que
j'ai dit oui tout de suite
tous sauf mireille mathieu et j'ai
franchement bien fait parce que ça a
changé ma vie
alors d'abord parce que le désert comme
souvent les environnements ans steve
c'est dans un endroit on apprend
beaucoup sur soi mais surtout parce que
j'ai rencontré des gens des gens qui
comme moi en temps d'une bonne sont dans
la vie entendent aussi des fausses notes
et même parfois mireille mathieu en
discutant avec ces personnes j'ai appris
qu'il y avait même un nom pour cette
sensation de malaise qu'on entend quand
il une fausse note dans la bande son ça
s'appelle la dissonance cognitive
pour faire simple la dissonance
cognitive
donc c'est ce malaise quand je vous
disais qui apparaît quand par exemple
une de nos actions rentre en
contradiction avec nos croyances ou nos
valeurs un exemple très concret qui
concerne peut-être certains d'entre vous
ici c'est le fait de fumer les gens qui
fument tous les jours barrillon des
paquets de cigarettes sur lesquels il ya
des photos de cadavres
on voit écrit soixante dix substances
cancérigènes et pourtant on sort sa
cigarette en exemple aux c'est pas mal
je redis plus et même plus que ça on
arrive à transformer ça en un instant de
plaisir alors que c'est un instant de
mort c'est tout ça la dissonance
cognitive
mais c'est pas le concept le plus
riche que j'ai rapporté du désert le
plus précieux ça m'est apparue par
hasard une nuit comme ça que j'étais
assis j'observais les gens à les gens
dansaient élevée toutes sortes de
personnes des petits des grands des
mains gelées gros et j'ai été frappé par
la beauté universelle de toutes ces
personnes
et cette beauté elle n'était pas dû à
une manière de danser exceptionnel
n'était pas du une veste imandt à sion
elle était simplement dû au fait que ces
gens étaient à l'ecoute de même étaient
bienveillants avec eux mêmes ils
n'avaient rien à faire du regard des
autres et sans prévenir ça m'a pris dans
le ventre un petit peu comme des
picotements comme des papillons
j'ai eu envie d'aller les rejoindre j'ai
eu envie d'aller de lancer alors ça peut
paraître banal mais pour moi c'était
quelque chose vraiment exceptionnel
parce que danser ça toujours été quelque
chose de très difficile c'était un
tableau existentielle c'est quelque
chose que je me suis toujours interdit
donc au bout de quelques minutes de
résistance inutile je me retrouve parmi
eux et je regarde mes pieds et là j'ai
un choc
mes pieds sont en train de faire des pas
de côté en vrai plein et écouter dans la
bande son
j'entends plus de fausses notes alors à
réfléchir sur cet épisode
j'ai commencé à en tirer une forme de
méthode
pourquoi pas faire des pas de côté pour
sortir de la dissonance cognitive
parce que finalement ce que j'ai fait
était rien d'exceptionnel j'avais
harmoniser le mouvement de mon corps et
le rythme de mes valeurs
alors vous allez me dire c'est bien joli
ce truc de hippies mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ça pour changer le monde
parce que c'est quand même le sujet qui
nous intéresse ici bien à force de
pratiquer le désert
j'en ai ramené une nouvelle stratégie
qui est celle que j'adopte encore
aujourd'hui et si pour changer le monde
ont commencé par essayer de se changer
soi même
pour se changer soi même quelque chose
de simple à portée de chacun qu'on peut
faire dans la vie de tous les jours
c'est un petit pas de côté vers la
bienveillance et l'empathie pour essayer
de sortir de la dissonance cognitive la
dissonance cognitive qui nous habite
dans nos quotidiens qui habite le monde
qui nous entoure
ma stratégie elle repose sur ce pari qui
est que plus on apprend à être
bienveillant avec soi même et plus on a
capacité à l'être avec les autres si
vous agitez vous ajoutez à ça la
propension des êtres humains est
d'ailleurs de pas mal de mammifères en
général à illimitée vous voyez qu'on
halal amorce d'un effet boule de neige
alors maintenant quand un joli concept
il manquait un outil pour pouvoir porter
la bonne parole
trouver le bon outil ça m'a pris un
certain temps mais un jour les planètes
s'alignent mon téléphone sonne et on
m'annonce la naissance d'une petite
chaîne youtube
elle crie déjà très fort au premier
épisode et elle a besoin d'un concept
elle a besoin d'idées elle a besoin
d'être nourris pour vivre alors tout de
suite mon esprit c'est clair et je me
dis et si c'était l'occasion d'essayer
de mettre en oeuvre cette stratégie
je rassemble un collectif avec deux
autres don quichotte contre la fin du
monde est pour pas porter malheur on
décide d'appeler ça et tout le monde
s'en fout comme ça si ça marche pas on
pourra dire bah oui c'était le concept
notre proposition allait assez simple on
va inviter nos spectateurs a essayé de
se changer eux-mêmes en leur disant que
ça pourra changer le monde
notre matière première comme je voulais
dit elle est toute trouvée c'est la
dissonance cognitive
alors je vous la corde pour régler la
dissonance cognitive à l'échelle du
monde
c'est pas un pas de côté qu'on vise
c'est un pas chassé mais au bout d'une
seule année d'existence on avance déjà
plus vite que je l'aurais jamais imaginé
notre petite chaîne elle rassemble
aujourd'hui 320 milles abonnés les
épisodes ont été vues plus de 12
millions de fois dans 22 pays
répartis sur les cinq continents et
surtout ma vie à moi elle est
complètement transformé j'ai quitté le
figaro j'ai repris ma quête et surtout
j'ai appris à m'écouter pour moi arriver
à ce début de succès ça a commencé par
faire un pas de côté et motorisé à faire
cette danse
et n'allez pas croire qu'on ne peut pas
commencer à changer le monde avec ce
genre de choses c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est un professeur en sciences
politiques américains qui s'appelle eric
à atg inuit et elle a étudié tous les
conflits majeurs les conflits sociaux
qui ont traversé l'occident au 20e
siècle
elle en tire en enseignement assez
incroyable une statistique qui dit qu'il
suffit d'une masse critique de 3,5 pour
cent d'une population pour opérer un
changement majeur dans une société pour
changer le paradigme
ça tombe bien qu'on soit en belgique 3,5
pour cent de la population belge
si je ne me trompe pas ça fait à peu
près 3 185 mille personnes vous voyez qu
avec 320 milles abonnés c'est pas encore
ça mais on n'est pas très très long
pour vous dire que on peut attendre
vingt ou trente ans pour vérifier si les
prophètes de la fin du monde nous ont
menti ou alors on peut décider de les
faire mentir aujourd'hui et maintenant
avec une chose toute simple qu'on peut
faire dans notre quotidien
c'est un petit pas de côté vers la
bienveillance et l'empathie parce qu'à
une seule chose dont je suis sûr
qu'elles que soient les prophéties ce
qu'il ne faut pas attendre d'être
heureux pour faire quelque chose c'est
faire quelque chose qui vous rendra
heureux c'est pour ça que je laisserai
le mot de la fin à l'un de mes
philosophe préféré j'ai nommé gandalf le
gris le sorcier du seigneur des anneaux
gandalf nous dit il n'ya finalement dans
la vie qu'une seule question qui mérite
vraiment qu'on s'y attarde
qu'allons-nous faire du temps qui nous
est imparti
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
mais